in Port Authority he had a meeting this
morning a lively discussion of a global
gender parity group we talked about the
issue of maintaining our commitment to
gender parity during a time of economic
stress we talked about it in the
corporate context and a major strategy
that evolved was to use the diversity in
the organization as a particular set of
skills or capabilities to address the
crisis actually use diversity as a way
to address the crisis for example women
oftentimes can communicate and lead
teams through a crisis situation by
reaching out and making an appeal to the
sense of community of Gilda crisis as
far as a barrier or constraint we talked
about the fact that a deep crisis
creates a risk aversion and fear and
that undermines the ability of the
organization to perform as a team and as
people get more and more concerned about
their own situation those concerns begin
to dominate the concerns with the
organization we concluded that it was
very important to renew one's commitment
to parody and equity in opportunity and
promotion and retention efforts and
talent development during periods of
economic stress alrighty